why do Chinese billionaires keep
disappearing while fond CEO of the
Investment Bank China Renaissance has
been missing since Thursday when the
news hit the street the stock dropped by
50 percent his team is currently in
damage control mode saying Fawn just had
a restless night maybe he partied a
little too hard so no need to worry but
they're just trying to save their
company from Total collapse in reality
disappearing billionaires are nothing
new in China but now it's getting even
worse the CCP recently launched a
Crackdown on the finance and tech
industry so now China's billionaires in
those sectors are fearing for their life
watch our video on how the world really
works with the link in the pin comment